let's just start Andy with a quick intro
of who you are and what you're working
on
sure my name is Andy Bromberg I've run
coinless coin Lass's platform where the
best digital asset companies manage
their token sales and we're also where
investors find high-quality deals in the
space so we're working on helping with
things like compliance something with
things like transaction processing for
deals in the space and then helping
investors who are also our clients find
these high-quality deals and invest in
them so broadly we you know provide full
services for sales like file coin and
block SEC and props and you know manage
their sale on the platform and then our
investors see the deals and then
separately we just run compliance for a
lot of sales as well so helping them
with know your customer anti-money
laundering an investor accreditation
which we could get into but the
nitty-gritty technical stuff you got to
do if you're selling - ok cool
yeah yeah and Ramon for people who don't
know you what are you working on yeah I
work for who I see and before I have my
own company and I work in video games
for singer for a while yep cool all
right you wanna start it off yeah so
this assume that we're starting a
project so how should we think about
this new mode of fundraising what kind
of project could be perfect for a token
cell versus going through an angel or
throne incubator right so really
interesting most projects not a good fit
for this funding model and we see a lot
you know the coin list has has done
three publicly on the platform so far
we've gotten over 900 in down so most
projects are not not really high quality
and not doing an IC o---- for the right
reason so when we think about the right
reasons for me it really comes down to
one of a couple use cases one is raising
money for protocols that need to be
distributed so file coins a great
example of that from protocol labs which
is a YC company and they're I think the
insight is that historically protocols
have only been funded by governments
academic coalition's sometimes really
huge companies because they're just
expensive to develop when you're
developing something that foundational
it's too costly for a start-up to
develop typically and so the ICO model
giving stakeholders a stake in that
protocol on that network is actually the
first time that we've had a way for new
protocols to emerge and fund and be
funded for small teams with great ideas
and what that's enabling is this world
of competitive protocols we're instead
of one just being the king by default
because it's the only one that's
capitalized well enough now we could
have competitive protocols going back
and forth so protocols is one example
the second is projects that have a
disproportionate advantage by having
early users be stakeholders on the
network so I'll break that down a little
bit yeah the idea there is that if you
can give the earliest users of a
platform some upside of the project
successful that's in theory good for
every project right you know if any
company gave the early user some equity
if that was easier than maybe that'd be
good but we really think I SEOs are good
for ones where there's a
disproportionate impact there so one
example might be if you had some sort of
of tokenized or distributed tor right
anonymous routing system where if there
aren't enough users on the platform it
just doesn't work it actually it's just
not anonymous or pseudonymous it fails
its mission so the idea there is if you
could give those users an early
incentive than perhaps that would be
incent tries to grow the network faster
get to that critical point where it tips
over and becomes useful much faster and
then be able to grow from there and then
the last category I'll mention is we're
early on this onebut
separate from those two securities
tokens so asset-backed tokens that are
taking an existing asset and tokenizing
them that's appealing but almost a
totally different category from from the
first and we could talk more about the
difference between those and then the
last thing I'll say there is
I imagine we're gonna find a ton more
use cases for AI cos we're basically a
year into the market right now it's
really young and so those first two
categories for the more technical ones
than the the asset-backed ones are the
ones that we find appealing so far but
there's gonna be way more beyond that as
this market evolves so you guys have
supported three out of nine hundred
projects that have come through what are
the criteria that you're looking at like
why why do you pick those yeah it's a
number of things so first of all I think
we're looking at the team and the team
quality
and the technical details is a team of a
history of shipping product and been
built something meaningful before so a
lot of the same things you'd look for
initially in a venture capital
investment right you know does the
product make sense you know have they
put enough work and already does it seem
like it has a real chance of success so
all of those components but then with
the ICO market what's different from all
the things you devalue a tin in the
venture capital market you know it's a
traditionally team product and market
the next step is a layer on top of that
because this is different and the the
components there that I think are
important that aren't as crucial in the
venture capital world are one the actual
structure of the sale and when I say
structure I mean two things I mean legal
structure and then how the sale is
actually structured in terms of the
economics of the sale in venture both of
those components are important but kind
of nailed down at this point things you
don't really see a lot of weird stuff
happening there but because the ICL
market show you I'm figuring out how to
structure these legally and then
figuring out you know what's the pricing
mechanism for the sale how do people get
in you know who do you decide how do you
decide who gets in all of that that
becomes important to evaluate in the
token industry and again we imagine
it'll become a little bit more
standardized or for time but it's early
there but then the the second piece
which is I think a little bit unique to
tokens is what we'd call the token
economic model when you have a token and
people are investing in the token you
need the value of the token have a
chance of going up right otherwise why
would you support this investment right
yeah and since this question of under
what conditions will value actually
accrue to the token what how can you
make it so that the token is actually
worth something and there's there's a
lot of theories out there another thing
we could we could dive really deep into
on how to value these tokens but if we
look at some of these systems verb for
tokens and maybe they have a really
great team maybe they have a market
that's really interesting maybe they've
built some real technology but then we
get to the token and you know either it
doesn't feel like values going to accrue
or it feels like the models broken
somehow and either good actors aren't
incentivized enough to do what they have
to do on the network or bad actors are
overly incentivized to do bad things to
the network and so digging in on that
model is such a new concept
that I think that'll that'll be a really
a really big piece of you know more and
more people are becoming experts on that
yeah or so early and the I think the
best experts I've seen are either
traditional economists who have looked
at you know game theory economic
incentives that's really what this is at
its core or actually from the gaming
industry because what are games but you
know a system of incentives and getting
people to do certain actions and so
thinking about game economies and how
those are designed I think we're gonna
see people move over from that industry
into this token economic evaluation
let's go back a little bit something you
said before you mentioned that and I
agree that this is great for projects
like Wikipedia or Linear's that are
foundational and traditionally have been
underfunded you see like Wikipedia's
always asking for donations because they
don't have enough money to to continue
so if I'm starting a project like that
how do you take on the recent statement
by the SEC chairman that most tokens are
securities instead of under he hasn't
seen any utility talk in person yeah so
I'll tweak that a little bit and I
should caveat this is not legal advice
and everyone should should get good
counsel and talk to your lawyers but so
I you know my reading of of Chairman J
Clayton the SEC Commissioner and
chairman his remarks over the past
couple months has been that he hasn't
seen an IC o---- and initial offering of
a coin that wasn't a sale of securities
and I think there's nuance there he's
not saying that the tokens will always
be securities he's saying with the
initial offering is securities and
without getting to in the weeds on the
securities law here there's this thing
called the Howey test which is you know
test in the United States whether
something's an investment contract or
security and I think what he's saying is
at the time of the offering these things
are gonna be securities because one of
the components of the Howey test is is
this project dependent on the efforts of
a single company a single entity and if
it is it's probably a security there's
other factors you have to consider but
it's probably a security and you know at
the time of the offering when the
offerings happening almost certainly
it's gonna be dependent on the efforts
of a single company and so it's it's
probably security at that point but you
know our belief and what's
being sorted out right now I think
publicly and and and you know try to be
sort out with the SEC and with these
projects is is it possible for something
to convert from being a security at one
point to a non security at some point
and if so where's that line and how do
you determine that so what we see is
this idea that yeah it looks like these
offerings gonna be offering some
securities and that's that's fine you
know we think a lot about how to sell
securities to certain sets of investors
there are other ways to sell securities
two different sets of investors and we
may just need to deal with the pain of
that but it's in the interest of
protecting investors and in the interest
of protecting the innovation that's
happening in the space and at some point
we will figure out where that line is
and how would these things can be non
securities at some point and be used way
more freely and traded more freely among
all users and investors and where's the
current thought on that conversion if
ever it's gonna happen yeah I think you
know I think there's not there's not a
really clear guidance the how we test is
a facts and circumstances based analysis
that's the term you'll always hear from
from lawyers everybody else you see is
facts and circumstances and so there's
there's as facts about what the thing is
and how it works and there's
circumstances of its current state and
so there's no at least right now there's
no bright line but you know when it
fails the prongs of the Howey test is is
when it if you pass the Howey test you
are secured if you fail you're
non-security counter-intuitively we want
people to fail this test ah so uh so
when it fails the Howey test at some
point when it fails these prongs and
that's when it'll become a non security
but the way to get there isn't you know
someone sitting in a room and saying
like yeah I'm feeling like this isn't a
security now you go to great counsel who
has deep securities law experience and
you say how about now yeah and they do a
legal analysis on it and they come to
you and they say here's our memo we
think this thing is now not a security
it may have been before it's now not a
security and then you can try and
operate with that assumption okay so in
this line of reasoning the soft that
coil is has used for block stack and
Falcon it could be a security at the
beginning and then when the token is
released that was transition into a
utility so so the idea is that the the
SAFF the simple agreement for future
tokens which was develop a protocol labs
and an Cooley is a security so it's a in
the same way
safe as a security it's a security your
song a promise of something in the
future is issued by a single company the
idea is that at some point when the
networks live and perhaps and the things
not considered a security anymore by
legal counsel at that point
saft holders will redeem for tokens and
those tokens will be non securities the
staff will always have been a security
but the tokens that get outputted at
some point are are non securities that's
the theory behind behind what this aft
it is and how it functions ok and so to
go back a little bit on on the point
about sales what does the test you guys
run like ok this seems like legit sale
and maybe give an example of like I
don't know about this other scenario
right
so for us it's actually this formal
legal diligence process as a result of
how were structured to make sure we're
in compliance we have what's called a
registered investment advisory entity
and coinless doesn't invest in these
projects but we make an investment
decision and recommend the investment to
investors that are clients of ours right
so there's a there's actually a formal
process we have internally that involves
you know a technical advisory committees
to some of the top developers in the
space a market advisory committee some
of the top investors and luminaries in
the space giving us feedback on the
project and then on top of that deep
legal diligence so doing things like bad
act actor checks on the projects
themselves doing things like you know
understanding how they operate how the
company operates how it's built out and
then really writing an investment memo
and digging in on the project itself on
some of the facets that we mentioned
before and coming out with a
recommendation and it goes to our
internal investment committee they come
out and they say hey we're good to go
we're not good to go and at that point
we can promote the sale and show the
sale to the investors that are clients
of ours on the platform separate from
that we have a whole separate compliance
service that will provide to people that
even if they don't pass that or even if
they don't want to go through that
process we can still help them with this
compliance piece and so even though
we've only you know run three of these
publicly and showing them on the
platform you know there are twenty fish
live right now that are using our
compliance solution back end and then do
they move into a valuation area like are
you providing guidance there as well we
informally help these companies figure
out their sales structure if you're
gonna work with them we want to be
helpful to our partners but ultimately
it's not our decision and you know if
they that's part of the investment
process the investment advisory
diligence process is understanding how
their value we can make an investment
recommendation without knowing what the
price is
yeah so that's part of the process we'll
we'll go back and forth of them on that
and help them sort that out based on
best practices and how the markets
evolving yeah and as for the next step
there once the due diligence is done and
you say okay this is every project what
are the options that a great protocol
has because I know there are different
regulations like the red a which ones
right so so this is under the assumption
that you're considered to be song a
security which again we believe all of
these are all of them have been thus far
so there's a number of when you sell a
security to investors you have two
options and the second option is a
million sub options
one is register the security with the
SEC so that's like when someone files
publicly right they say I'm registering
this through the SEC and we're some of
the security the the second is to use an
exemption the SEC hasn't taken hasn't
accepted any securities registration so
far it we don't expect them to that's
not the path any of these sales have
taken but that's fine
the a legitimate second option is
exempting and and just give a sense
there we when we do venture capital
investments we often exempt them so this
is well understood you you're allowed to
exempt these things instead of
registering them there are a bunch of
exemptions for selling securities and
it's actually probably instructive to
run through a few of the ones that are
being used a lot right now and we see as
interesting so the one that coinless
deals with the most is what's called reg
d 506 C and this is selling to only
accredited investors so people with the
correct specific criterion worth getting
into but significant net worth or income
who are considered sophisticated
investors and you're allowed to sell to
them with certain restrictions and
limits but that's what that's what we do
for the most part so the filed coin and
block stack and prop sales that were
helped by coin list we're all reg D 506
C offerings and part of that is you need
to check these people's accreditation
status you need to get evidence of net
worth or income that's something that we
help with so that's one another is
what's
I'll drag D 506 B phone before that and
that's for very small private sales
where you have an existing relationship
the issuer's an existing relationship
with the investors and at that point you
can have the investors a test that
they're accredited as opposed to
providing all this evidence it's a
little bit easier but it's way more
restrictive in terms of how many
investors you can have in and of course
you can't do it publicly so part of 506
C is general solicitation saying
publicly the the sales happening 506 B
you can't do that it's only private
people you have a relationship with
outside of that there's a bunch more so
there's reg CF crowdfunding regulation
which came in after the JOBS Act in 2012
and that is actually allowing you to
sell to unaccredited investors but
there's a similarly a bunch of
restrictions on that you can only raise
1.0 7 million dollars with reg CF right
now although that that may change soon
she does seem enough to république
that's what exactly is a sister company
of ours and they do reg CF offerings so
they sell to an accredited investors
they have actually a whole Republic
crypto division now that is doing just
these crypto deals so for example with
the prop sale sometimes you can get the
benefits more than one of these for
props we sold a bunch of props to
investors you know using coinless and
then separately republic sold a million
dollars worth to unaccredited investors
you got both those user sets on top
that's just a couple of those that are
worth mentioning reg s is another
exemption you can use to sell to
international investors so no US
investors there's Geographic
restrictions on how its transferred and
all of that but you then have to comply
with those countries securities laws as
opposed to the US so you don't need to
check them to u.s. accreditation
standards you can check them against
that country where the investors from
well let's go a little bit deeper on
that because I know like with crypto
stuff like the International things are
like you know are you in Switzerland or
Gibraltar or wherever like where are
things going in the future I know right
now it seems completely fragmented
everyone's operating at a different pace
with different regulations where do you
see things going I think we're really
gonna have different projects do
different things and one of the
beautiful things about crypto is that
its global its distributed yeah right
and and that's both I think just
practically true a lot of way more big
projects for the stage we're at are
around the world and suppose being you
know right in the US as compared to
other industries that's that's really
interesting but it's also I think a
philosophical thing that crypto is
distributed yeah its nature and so
people you know take that to its fullest
extent and distribute themselves there
are advantages and disadvantages to each
of these jurisdictions like and I'll
probably say this 40 times on this
podcast we are so early in the industry
yeah that most of these countries have
not really nailed down exactly how these
things gonna be treated some of them
need to clarify those securities law as
a result of this and so we're gonna see
a lot of things shift I really believe
that the u.s. is going to do the right
thing the regulators have been
incredibly thoughtful so far they've
taken their time and understanding the
space they're now starting to make
statements but what we love to hear from
them and what they're saying is we're
gonna apply existing regulations they're
not trying to write a whole new book of
laws on how to govern icos
not interesting to them not interesting
to us what the answer is is securities
law commodities law currency law pretty
well lit well understood areas of the
law there's some edge cases around
crypto that we need to figure out
exactly how to apply them so that's the
challenging part this question of you
know when to something transition to
being a charity but we'll get there and
so I think we'll still see a ton of
sales happening the US and at the end of
the day just practically if you want to
run big token sales there's a lot of
capital in the US there's a lot of money
here yeah and if you're selling to US
investors even if you're even if you're
not in the US you got to comply with
u.s. securities law so at the end of the
day I think a lot of projects will be
headquartered in the US or even if
they're not they'll sell to US investors
they'll need to abide by these laws
right but there are certainly advantages
to being in other jurisdictions as well
for all sorts of reasons from regulatory
to even just where the talent is in some
cases yeah another point there is that
many networks assume that the only path
is to do a token sell but there are
other distribution mechanisms like air
drops for example what do you think
about that or I'm I love air drops I'm
obsessed with air drop please define
that yeah so an air drop well I'm gonna
loosely define it because it's people
are sorting out how to how to do it
right now
an airdrop is a mechanism to give users
tokens without them paying for those
tokens usually around the launch our
network or early on a networks life
cycle a couple points to make here one
airdrops are not a way to skip
securities law so if your token is still
a security which many of these are you
can't airdrop tokens to everyone that's
actually considered and again not legal
advice you should talk to counsel but
considered a securities offering and and
the the case law for that dates back to
the dot-com boom interestingly when
companies were giving away shares and
the SEC said hey you can't give away
shares that's securities offering
because the user the person is
exchanging some information they're
giving maybe their email address or
their address or some information you're
giving them securities that securities
offering you gotta abide by securities
laws you can't just airdrop that's not a
way to skip ya the issues with with
securities law but to give some examples
of airdrops tagging it's a really
powerful concept and and taking a step
back for a minute i cos have kind of
coupled together to ideas fundraising
for an underlying company and
distribution of the token to early users
and and we're trying to do both of SES
but it turns out that you know maybe the
investor is in a sale aren't the same
people as the users hmm so the idea that
maybe we could decoupled us a little bit
in some cases and have a sale to
investors and then an airdrop to users
makes a lot of sense so a few I break
airdrops down into three three
categories one is what I would call like
broad or universal airdrops
so the way this works is that and amis
ago is an example of this the way this
works is that you take an existing
blockchain so aetherium and you just
give everyone on that who has a balance
on that blockchain who has some of that
token your tokens and you could do it in
different distribution but you could do
it so everyone gets one token you could
do it so they get it proportional to how
much they have you could use all sorts
of functions there but the idea is just
broad distribution yeah right give
everyone who has this and and and this
is interesting we've never really been
able to do this before give someone a
product because we have been able to
know how to reach people right if I
wanted to just you know give everyone a
phone
how do i how do I give people phone how
do I know where to find them but because
these addresses are public you can just
airdrop it and just gives back to what
you said before about aligning the
incentives and then everyone has the
skin in the game because if I get these
free tokens and they are valuable yeah
incentivized to grow the network
absolutely and then the two other
categories that I break here drops down
into is one based on off chain data and
one based on on chain did so what I mean
by that is off chain would be if I have
an existing service with users and I
just want to give those users tokens so
this is not I know something about these
users not because of some blockchain
status but just because I know something
about them they're my users so número is
an example of this distributed network
for data scientists to solve these
financial problems and make predictions
about the market they gave their users
tokens they just gave it to them
more recently they actually just
announced that they're gonna give all
Kaggle users tokens so they're using off
chain data to to give tokens to people
the last category and one that I think
is really interesting and hasn't been
done much if at all yet is using on
Shane data so what I mean by that is
these block chains are public you can
see the transactions and you can't
necessarily link them to real world
identities so you know gibberish
aetherium address you don't know it's me
but you can get data out of that we've
got this whole ledger of transactions
and so the idea there is by analyzing
that you can pick out which addresses to
give tokens to so an example might be if
I was if I was gonna start augur let's
say a prediction market platform already
exists but if I was starting augur maybe
I would go to you know the ethereum
blockchain and I would look at I would
do transaction analysis and figure out
which addresses which users were
transacting frequently with aetherium
gambling sites right so there's a bunch
of gambling sites you can yet spend
either gamble fun yeah sure so you can I
could look at that because those
addresses are known I know which
addresses belong to the gambling
platforms so I could see users that are
transacting a ton with those those are
likely gamblers I'm building a
prediction market it seems like there's
a nice Venn diagram overlapping those
users and then I can
give those users tokens immediately so
this is the idea that you can bootstrap
network effects off of existing networks
because all their transactions are
public yeah it's a really cool idea
hasn't been explored a lot yet but I
think resi more on Shan analysis for
deciding who to give tokens mmm that is
super interesting and like and going
back to getting things rolling like
really getting the ball rolling with
your company you mentioned big money
before some of these companies in a
hundred million dollars two hundred
million about three hundred million
dollars someone asks kind of the
inverted question which is the FinTech
hub asks is there going to be a
liquidity crunch for post ICO companies
yeah it's a it's such a different model
right the the way these things are
developing is is changing constantly
these mostly these companies are trying
to raise enough but they never have to
raise again right and part of the idea
there is is uh this just requires I
think a mindset shift and how these
businesses are run these companies in
their ideal form don't make money from
transactions on the network right the a
big piece this is removal of
rent-seeking middlemen in the process so
a lot of these companies business model
is actually more like an investment
company they own a bunch of the tokens
they do work just as a contributor to
the network to try to make the network
worth more so the value of their stake
increases but they're not there's
nothing coming in it's just they have a
bunch of tokens and the value should
increase over time so the idea is that
they raise enough to get the network out
into the wild and built by them built by
other people contributing to it it's
totally open and increasing the value of
their stake the investors are investing
and increasingly are getting locked up
for some time period you want long-term
support from your investors so maybe
they don't get their tokens for 12
months or 18 months it was investing
scheduler maybe it's way longer it's
years and years and so you know I think
that the idea of a liquidity crunches is
interesting but I started to find out
how exactly it applies right yeah
because you know that the companies
again ideally should it should it work
raise the money start building it get it
out into the wild and then
just keep building it because they want
their value to increase the investors
are holding for some period of time wait
shorter than how long they hold for
startups right whoosh I mean you Dropbox
I hear today 11 years later one way to
think about it is that for a company
when their goal is to maximize the value
for their shareholders but if you're a
company that are starting a network yeah
then your goal ideal is to take the
company out right yeah so then you are
just one more participant in the network
with hopefully a lot of tokens because
do you think that a lot of networks are
gonna suffer from not having enough
tokens to support the underlying
protocol as in the the company building
the network of the network itself yeah
the company but in building a network
that dear son you know three or four
years they didn't design the token
economics right I think well I think
they I think actually the inverse is
true I think a lot of companies have too
much of these networks and it's gonna
really hurt the incentives for other
people to contribute yeah and what's
gonna happen is these networks gonna be
a forked yeah so if you're sitting there
and there's a really cool amazing
technology built this technology is
open-source by nature right so if I'm
sitting there and say there's an amazing
band with sharing tokenized Network and
the team's great technology is awesome
it's like really getting going but the
team owns 50% of the network I sit there
and I say well that seems wrong and I'm
gonna build a great team we're gonna
fork this network we're gonna do a great
public push to make people aware of that
and we're gonna reduce the team stake
down to 10% 5% one person who knows
where these things end up well will the
market push it to 0% well so I I don't
this is a you know I think the mark this
is what I love about the token market as
a whole it is the purest form of markets
yeah right it's all open people can make
decisions 0% I don't see because I do
think that there is value to strong core
contributor teams right having it having
a core set of core contributors that are
building the protocol and they're not
the only ones they don't have you know
special rights or anything like that
but but their core and building the
protocol I think the market will want to
reward that and so when I think about
that and you know you can you see maybe
a an amazing team with a 10% stake of
you know solid team with a 5% stake you
know a weak team with a point two
percent stake and no team with a zero
percent stake I think you end up with
starting with a great team but perhaps
over time as the network value increases
the incentives change such that maybe a
great team is willing to do five percent
or great team is willing to do two
percent and you may see a lot of Forks
on the way down I certainly think the
intuitions right I agree with that that
it drives down over time but I don't
think it drives to zero okay and it's
really interesting because mentioned is
networks on a lot of the percentage of
their these teams on a bigger percentage
of the network what's the role of the
investor like crypto fans that are
getting in early
placing a lot of capital there and then
getting a huge chunk of our network that
is supposed to be owned by all the
participants yeah I think the role the
investors is to get the network started
right same same as an early stage
company and seed investors its to be
helpful get them relationships they need
help them build the team do all those
components I think it's the exact same
situation if the market decides at some
point that too much is owned by certain
parties it may get formed like this
we're gonna see a lot more governance
struggles over these networks as they go
live because the thing to remember here
is a lot of this and again for early in
the market but a lot of this is so
theoretical there's not a lot of
networks that are live and being used
right now there's no real incentive for
governance struggles for works for I
mean what are you forking there's not
not much to do so right and we've seen a
few obviously the Bitcoin Forex etherium
Forks but there's not a lot that are
live as more networks ago live which i
think is gonna happen this year as the I
cos of 2017 starting to go live we will
see a lot more battles over this and it
might be that if investors on a huge
stake in the network doesn't think
that's right they may try and fork it
but the the piece to remember there too
is you still need have a team behind it
like focused on building the protocol
and so if the best team is building it
an investor zone some percentage that
may be worth it to stick with the
investor zone I'm a percentage if it
means that you still get to keep the
team there
working on making it the best possible
protocol so another question from
Twitter related to this Jordan Jackson
asks do you think there will basically
be one dominant protocol for each of
these categories you know it's like
hosting payments whatever it might be uh
I believe that I believe a couple things
one is that I believe a lot of it
related to this questions really do this
question a couple things yeah so so one
is that I I do believe that at any given
time there's probably one but it goes
back to this markets point it is such a
free market here that there will be
constant competition whether it's from a
fork whether it's from a new protocol
and so I I don't think we're gonna get
to a place where there's a dominant one
of them were just in stasis and nothing
ever changes I do think that there will
be constant competition things will pop
up and things will go down and at any
given time they'll probably be a couple
that are competing for that title but it
does feel like there's going to be
consolidation interoperability is a huge
huge issue yeah the the other belief I
have and and this is one that I'm a
strong belief weakly hell that I think
we're you know early enough that we
don't know how it's gonna play out I
lean towards fewer but more generalized
protocols with platforms networks
capabilities technologies to allow for
inter protocol interoperability so what
I mean by that is different protocols of
different advantages so we could build a
generalized one that's to over simplify
a little bit really fast or one that's
slow but highly programmable right or
you know they might have all sorts of
different advantages and the idea that
we could then use layers on top of these
protocols to link them together and
there's a number of projects out there
so polka dot cosmos that allow for these
inter protocol interoperability is
interesting to me because the there
would be a real pain in managing a
wallet that had a thousand crypto
currencies one for every single use case
I have right I go to CVS and buy
something I pay with one token this with
another seems very unlikely so the idea
that we'll have a few generalized ones
but
I I find it hard to believe we get to
one hole and this is there some people
that believe there will only ever be one
yeah right
yeah and that hard to believe that we'll
get to a place where all those
components can be satisfied right
because it does feel like there are just
some real limitations on the trade-offs
between those different components yeah
you know some are more distributed some
are less faster slower secure not scary
all these different components so I
think it'll be a bunch but not you know
a million and then they'll be
interoperable between them and in this
train of thought do you agree with the
theory of the fad protocol that there's
thrown out a lot in crypto that most of
the values gonna accrue to the base
layer that can be aetherium and
everything that is on top it's gonna get
less and less of that value I do
generally agree with that with with it I
guess a twist in that I think there's a
world where some closer to the
application layer things do well but as
securities this is a little bit of a
wonky point but you know had and I'm not
the only person who's had this idea
there's a few people thinking about it
but an interesting concept around what
I'm calling index tokens right now
although it's not it not a great name if
anyone has a better one please
tweet at me and let me know but the idea
is that there's a that we don't have to
have a no middleman world if some
protocols take some fees for being
helpful or some you know slightly closer
so some more some higher up protocols
take some fees it may not be the end of
the world if it's the best option and I
think there's kind of a knee-jerk
reaction of like no middlemen that
script up ideally I think we get to that
place but there's some that that could
be worth it so if we were to be
designing a solution that did something
for protocols so let's say we built
built a tokenize network that made
protocols more secure right or encrypted
protocols transactions something like
that so it's helping protocols so it's a
little sitting on top right perhaps that
layer that token that network could take
fees from those protocols per
transaction right and so so maybe the
network chooses
a you know so much it's helping a
theorem so if they pay so many either to
that to that layer on top per
transaction what would be interesting
there is that that that token would then
be an index across all the projects that
it's helping right if you're playing
with some ether bitcoins penguins
Bitcoin no file coins point paying with
some file coin and it all goes into this
thing and then that one has its own
token but the token doesn't isn't used
on the network it just represents this
pool of assets that are being accrued
for the network it's that thing again
not a lawyer but it's probably a
security it's an investment right here
it's saying this is but values accruing
to that token possibly in a very
meaningful way yeah the more projects
that get on it the more it's worth and
so this this token off sentence value so
that maybe the protocols are accruing a
ton of value because they're being used
and the values currently but maybe
there's this layer on top that is also
gaining value as the protocols do right
as aetherium gets more transactions it's
paying more fees to this network still
worth it but that now is a current ton
of value as well so I am a believer in
the fad protocols but I think we'll see
more layers on top of it as well let's
talk a little bit about the the end-user
layer so it's custom in like nine years
since the Bitcoin white paper what was
published but you know many people say
firstly that we have really final in
consumer cases that are in use right now
yeah what is your answer to that so nine
years since Bitcoin absolutely but it
hasn't been that long for other tokens
and and I think bitcoins use case for
from my perspective is you know store
value it's a digital gold I think it's
doing that so there's an end user use
case but that's the one for Bitcoin I
think these new ones are so young yeah I
think we had a period of experimentation
a few years ago where a few came out
obviously a theory I'm and some others
but it was so early we're figuring out
how these token economic models work we
still are but the ico market and this
wave of new tokens it's really just 2017
and really just kind of mid to late 2017
and so without trying to make excuses
for the industry if you're doing a sale
17 and you're building something
meaningful based on the results of that
sale you know takes 9 12 15 18 24 months
we're just now getting to the point
where hmm that time periods being hit so
I I do think the next call it 12 months
will be a real trial period for these
these networks that are just now going
live post IC o----
after some time to build and actually
make that meaningful technology so you
know without wanting to without meaning
to weasel out of the question and say
there's there's nothing I excite agree
that there are not a lot of real and
user use cases out there right now I
just think we're just now getting to the
time for these gonna get this call my
needs are you on right I'm I can't
answer any questions but what I was but
I'm a big big fan actually that's one
that is worth worth mentioning yeah I
think elect evils collectors one of the
few collectibles are interesting because
they're the the collectibles protocol
the technology behind it the ERC 721
which is the the component added to
aetherium to allow for collectibles or
at least the first one very technically
challenging particularly steam built
that and and that's really impressive
but then building a collectible on top
of it just a raw collectible with no
kind of interaction mechanics is
actually not that hard that's
technically challenging but but not you
don't to build a whole new protocol and
so I think we will see a lot of value in
collectibles accrue because those can
just be spun out really quickly yeah
then you get into more interesting
mechanics around collectibles
interacting with each other can you
build a game where the collectibles
that's challenging to build but I do
think the what crypto kitty showed us is
you can put something out there that in
the in the distributed blockchain world
that doesn't need to have pure technical
value to the end-users you can just
build a really great product and people
want to use it I say this all the time
most people don't care about how
websites work they don't care it's not
an important part like I mean it's
important in how it functions it's
important in like being secure and all
that stuff but at the end of the day
like how many people know how Facebook
functions no and I think to that point
we are just now entering a time of
now what I call the professionalization
of the space more people with expertise
building businesses more people to
expertise shipping products mmm coming
to the sky so far it's been so
beautifully driven by pure technology
let's build these deep protocols the
infrastructure layer that needs to exist
that has to continue forever and it will
continue forever but we're just now
getting to a place where the user bases
are big enough the incentives are strong
enough that real product builders real
product people are coming in and
thinking about how to build it and I'd
argue that you know the cryptic ladies
team axiom Zen team that's a great
example
they build products and they said the
infrastructure exists now we see a use
case let's build a great product yeah
we're gonna see a lot more of that over
the coming months so another question
from Twitter johannes asked what are
your recommendations for how someone
ought to think about implementing an
onboarding users to a protocol and maybe
there are something like cryptic kiddies
whose primary users are non-technical so
in that case right you're like you're
talking about the meta mask and doing
all this stuff like what do you guys
think I think it's just a function of
meeting better products and so you know
one one really good example of this it
this is actually it's an interesting
question because it's almost not a
blockchain question Yeah right it's in
the same way yeah that's you know it
feels like asking like how do you
onboard someone to you know a a social
graph and connect with other nodes and
the answer is like you build facebook
right let me click an ad friend button
and that's me onboarding to a social
graph and so the UI's you know aren't
really there yet one example that I
thought was really impressive is for an
airdrop a company called bloom which is
a decentralized credit scoring
application protocol they didn't airdrop
in partnership with with earn comm tear
drop a bunch of bloom tokens to users
and they just did a great job building
this product their drops are hard you
have to use meta mask of some other
wallet and send aetherium address this
that the other thing and they just built
a beautiful process where you basically
just had to click a bunch of times and
you said I want this and then it
redirected and something else popped up
and said this is the button you want to
click here's what it does right that sir
it was still you know a long process
that's just a function of you know the
ecosystem being young and the tools not
being developed fully yet but they made
it really easy explanations click
buttons and at the end of the day the
answer to that question which is a very
good one how do you onboard users to the
protocol if the users are non-technical
is make it obvious what is happening and
make it easy to click buttons and type
things and have that happen
yes building UI is in building with
technology to support that because it
comes back to what are you using the
blockchain for for example in in the
case of critter kitties you're just
proving a scarcity you have this unique
kitty that nobody else has but the user
doesn't care about anything else meta
mas so I think even what Co invest it
that is you own the private keys so the
user doesn't need to deal with meta mass
on all this you can just that can be a
real interesting approach to this think
more projects we're gonna see they can
totally agree with that yeah and
actually on the coinbase side do you see
index funds becoming like the default
way of investing it yeah it depends what
you mean by default there's a lot of
different potential parties here so it's
a one note and I'll get back to the core
question is a tiny percentage of the
money in crypto is professionally
managed right yeah it's a depending on
who you ask
you know about ten percent of capital
and crypto is professionally managed by
professional investors when you look at
a developed market like the US equities
market or any other major market that
number is 95 96 97 99 % professionally
managed so for those people you know
largely index funds won't be the answer
although in some cases they'll make
significant investments in index funds
but this the amount of professional
investment is as a percentage of the
total capital I think is going to
increase dramatically and we've got a
long way to go and and part of that as
an aside contributes to the volatility
professional investors tend to in most
cases help manage volatility for an
asset class because their professional
vest errs and you know I think a lot of
the volatility comes from the fact that
it's minimally professionally managed
right now for retail investors I think
that we will get to a place where index
funds are really significant investments
for retail investors but in these early
days before the market really matures
people like making their crypto
investments right they like thinking
it's fine
as Gumley i wanna buy that yeah it's
gambling at speculation on which ones
are gonna win but when people are making
investments I do think that they enjoy
it at this at this early stage mmm
so I think that we'll see a significant
inflow to the index funds there'll be
some very successful index fund products
that come out but I'm not convinced that
right now it'll be end up being a
massive percentage in the same way it is
in the in the US equities markets do you
default to asset allocation that you
recommend to people I don't make
investment recommendations right but I
do think that broadly as with any asset
class it's smart to first of all we're
very early in yoga system for the
millionth time invest money you're
willing to burn it's you know yeah I can
vesting in seed arounds that startups if
not even more risky yeah invest money
that you are willing to just have
disappear don't over index into this and
then you know once you do I think as
with everything a pretty traditional
strategy is of the money you're willing
to burn you know most of it you may want
to put in the the stronger more
established once it's all early now but
breaking down kind of into the stronger
more established ones makes sense and
then if you want to throw some bets into
things that you're interested in if you
have some insight into yeah and dig dig
in on those spaces but you know I think
it makes sense people to invest in
projects they understand and so aside
from kind of core investments in the
space or indexing in his space you know
once you understand is always a good bet
well once you understand that's like
should be exploded out as well right so
if you're I mean if you're in retail
non-technical investor how do you come
to understand some of these white papers
yeah I I think I hope we're moving away
from just white papers so a white paper
is really kind of an overloaded term
yeah and it's just become this two
factor thing in the crypto industry I
think the best projects are moving
generally they may have a white paper
but they're moving away okay what a
white paper originally was is a
reasonably technical explanation of how
the system works you know some people
want to really understand that and if we
were making an investment here in a big
data company maybe there's some
investors that really have the
capability and ability to understand
the deep technical piece of how some set
of algorithms works and maybe they do
their diligence on that but plenty of
people invest in you know very technical
companies without understanding exactly
how the system works and I don't think
that's wrong I think that's okay as long
as someone's doing their diligence and
then you're doing the diligence some
things that you care about for
investments capable of different
weighting yeah people care more about
the team market product with technology
and that's totally okay so I do think
these protocols should publish white
papers or something like it but that
should be a deeply technical exploration
of exactly what it is they're building
and you shouldn't have to assume it as
an investor that you need to read and
understand that you should be able to
invest in something without
understanding what you know proof of
space-time is for file coin that's a
crazy technical concept and I didn't
make that up that is actually what so
probably cool yeah so so I think they'll
start to release more will see investors
get more sophisticated about doing their
diligence and we'll see companies get
more sophisticated about what they
disclose and what materials they put out
and there'll be a happy medium where you
know investors get the information they
need without needing to understand you
know right how the protocol works you
know at that point I totally agree I
think you start up fundamental society
in the market always apply but then I
hope we see more working networks before
they try to talk himself to do a talk
and so yeah so the network is already
working and then you don't have just a
white paper you have a white paper and I
work in network and especially for
products that are more end-user
applications you know the user as we
talked before he doesn't need to know
try worse but if it's something that you
care about yeah and it's working already
you maybe live in the project yeah
absolutely
and then what about the people who want
to join these teams like how are they
what are your thoughts around like
vetting a project as an employee yeah I
think it goes back to some of the things
that I said earlier about how you know
how coin list evaluates these projects
yeah there's a lot of components that
are the same as evaluating any other
company right so it's not it's like a
whole new world it's I mean it's the
same elephant yeah all right so so
evaluate those things but then layer on
top of that some of the token specific
pieces and again the people there's not
a lot of people that are experts on the
tokens
specific pieces so far you know
structuring these different things in
the token economics so ask smart people
right in the same way that if you're a
non-technical person going to join deep
learning startup ask some technical
friends you know what are the merits of
this is an interesting ask some
investors in the project you know talk
to have those conversations and you know
be intentional about finding out things
about the team and the product the
history and all of that but a lot of
that you can do on your own
if you have good intuitions there spend
more time with external sources
evaluating the token economics
maybe the technical details that's not
something you understand the history of
the team and and digging in on that but
you know at the end of the day there are
you know people join companies whose
technology and products they don't fully
understand all the time it's necessary
yeah and and I think it's a lot of the
same same mechanics there and how did
you get interested in this pace I got
interested in the space from a professor
of mine University biology Srinivas on
who now runs earn comm and he he was a
professor and a number of us took this
class at Stanford called startup
engineering and he developed
relationship with him and and after the
class ended he told a bunch of us
Bitcoin it's a great thing and and you
know we looked at it more like this
school by bit coin magic Internet money
like I don't think this is a real thing
but but he convinced a few of us to buy
just a couple and and then we ended up
as a result of that actually starting
the the Stanford Bitcoin group this was
back in 2012-2013 and we did some really
cool stuff we did you know research on
you know some of the economic impacts of
bitcoins this was around when the Cyprus
an economic collapse happens to how
could crypto have helped that we did
some build some really cool projects in
the space and and did a lot of
evangelism ran up and down Sand Hill
Road pitching Bitcoin to investors not
we didn't want to raise money were just
saying you should be interested in
Bitcoin doesn't work had the time these
a toss up there are some people that got
it some that didn't I know we may have
I needed to hone our pitching skills a
little more but you know it's
interesting now to see some those people
we talked to and how they're thinking
that's evolved on the space so we there
were kind of seven of us in that group
most of whom are now still in crypto and
you know we did a lot of cool stuff
there and you know my interests evolved
from then I guess my last question is if
you weren't working on coinless what
would you be working on that is a really
hard question part of what I love about
coinless and I think what would inform
that decision is supporting building
tools for or services for the companies
that are building great protocols in
this space right I don't have a protocol
in my head that needs to be started
tokenized
right doubt yeah there are some great
protocol teams it is it is very early
and so I you know what I love is this
idea of supporting this ecosystem and
bringing value to the people that do
have these brilliant ideas and rather
than going in and adding skills to a
single project because I like a lot of
them I would much rather say how can I
help all of these projects and so it
would be something else kind of services
or tool oriented picks and shovels for a
token industry because I fundamentally
believe in what's happening in a
meaningful way and and want to want to
support it but what I would say is for
other people thinking about the space
especially if people that are not deep
in crypto already these projects need
you like there are they have every role
open they're figuring out how to run
these new types of businesses whether
you're technical or a marketer or sales
or operations or anything else these
companies need you and going out and
finding a team that you identify with as
with any startup but also a use case
that you understand again you don't
understand the technology but something
you believe in well that's fine
sure file storage I mean this this is
their potential solving a massive
problem here and introducing a whole new
economic model or any of these other
projects it is it is worthwhile and they
need help from you know people that are
coming from outside crypto so it's an
exciting time in the industry they saw
the vendors in the space it reminds me a
little bit of the early time of a
start-up before the dot-com boom you can
see the think I know yeah
so on that energy and also one of the
things that's so attractive about the
space is just the number of a players
coming into the space yes the brainpower
concentrated here is when I say here I
mean in the industry but it's worldwide
is so high and so much fun that you get
to work with such brilliant people
excited about making a meaningful change
in the way that companies projects
technologies are built in the future
that I think it's just hard to find an
ethically understand a sound network
effect that's well the best people are
gonna have tracked right this people
that's exactly right yeah yeah totally
alright man well thanks for coming in
thanks for having me thank you
you